this week we've got vampire infections
Wow
whites only what and human composts
human Campos Campos one place that's
still segregated in the whole entire
world all right our first story vampire
infection there have been two confirmed
HIV people like people have contracted
HIV after getting these vampire facials
at this particular spa what's a vampire
facial I thought vampires got in fact
wait and then the new one in New Mexico
what's up what's a vampire it's where
they take that your blood and they spin
it in a thing they put it back on your
face and it's supposed to like
rejuvenate your skin is blood their own
blood how do you get made it popular
back in 2013
that means the tools the instruments are
contaminated oh because I thought people
were doing that with their [ __ ] PMS
remember that why oh girl I was doing
the one we were told the battery the PMS
not the PMS the blood yeah menstrual is
for ms/ms PMS is premenstrual okay
whoops yeah whoops I [ __ ] up yeah you
like that right there you not know I
should know this I should know this it's
so important
oh it really is though I'm Joe [ __ ]
blood [ __ ] blood there we go
PBS yeah PMS rates and and period week
are completely different attitudes like
it's like dr. Jekyll mr. Hyde oh yes it
is it's all crazy to me so this it's
called VIP spa and Albuquerque how
cookie yeah so now the Department of
Health is warning people that if you
ever got a vampire facial or any type of
facial that that required like you know
needles or any sort of way that you can
contaminate yourself with this stuff
which is HIV hepatitis B and hepatitis C
then to go in and get a free testing
because there have been two confirmed
HIV yeah yeah you go in trying to be
beautiful you leave with AIDS
that's a really good slogan for them
come in trying to be beautiful you'll
leave with these they didn't pay for
that that's why that's what's so scary
though they didn't turn it to AIDS yet
though right it's HIV first I even freak
out when I'm getting like a pedicure
manicure cuz I'm like I need to make
sure that shit's sterile because I'm not
trying to catch you're gonna make sure
they get that [ __ ] out of that blue [ __ ]
I'm saying it's yes I get so scared
like I'm that sensitive you to get that
light [ __ ] put that [ __ ] away Joe's
the one sterilizing the tools I put the
light on it
you shouldn't I got HIV well I don't
know exactly what they were doing but
they were just saying that they were
practicing like unsafe practices lazy
asses because what I call me from your
own blood yeah exactly your own so does
that mean all the employees now should
get HIV for fair and squares well it's
just this one spot owner and so they're
saying that she was she didn't even have
a license
oh so maybe the whole spa should get HIV
I guess well definitely they're gonna
get sued and she's gonna lose everything
yep two people yeah life is changed
forever yeah you're gonna you might die
so now it's out as bad cuz I've heard
people like treatment
yeah treatments forever yeah but what
does it do for your sex life though like
Magic Johnson live well he just cleaned
his blood out till it was all gone so
he'd have enough money you could be here
but transfusion I got fat he's the only
guy with HIV that fat yes that's our you
gain weight on HIV magic magic
he is magic well isn't he cured of it
though yeah cleared out all of his blood
so he kept on getting blood transfusions
I just I didn't know that it was even
possible to cure HIV and he got it cured
when it was like like what in the 90s
right no he got it cured we said I think
it came out it was like maybe like maybe
like haters he's been going through tree
yeah he he got diagnosed in the 90s and
he's been doing treatments for over a
couple decades yeah I remember my mom
had to explain to me why he was when I
was like six because they were talking
about Magic Johnson and I guess he got
cut on the court and like everyone is
scared to go
close to him and like she was telling me
about it and I was like that's so crazy
that's probably why I was so good at
basketball everyone's like I can make
these shots nobody wants to guard a
mishit the whole procedure though it's
supposed to rejuvenate your skin what do
they do they poke a million holes yeah
so they'd be like extract blood from
your face yeah and then by poking holes
and then they'd put in a centrifuge to
like to separate the platelets thank you
to separate the plasma and then they use
that to inject it back in I don't trust
nobody supposed to be whooshing a
turnover of skin cells but they're
saying that the benefits are disputed so
if they're not doctors I don't trust him
to [ __ ] do blood [ __ ] with me
yeah sorry that like I don't want
anything that's I don't like lunch
there's too much hearsay about it you
know it needs to be like just a proven
fact like if you do this this is the
result it can't just be like there's a
chance it might work well I mean but
we're ready taking like multivitamins
right like that kind of hearsay like
whose multivitamins do more for people
who don't have a variation in their diet
like like well can someone explain this
to Steve cuz we had a huge argument
about it I was like yeah well you should
take vitamins cuz he was constantly
getting sick stubborn guy though I not
really you know my gosh should be like
don't take anything you look so [ __ ]
boring
we're the COFF that hasn't gone away for
like forever and I'm like you should
take vitamins because you're always
getting sick and he's like vitamins are
[ __ ] and he goes off on his rant
about how vitamins are [ __ ] I'm like
he's like did you know that like you
should be getting all that from food I'm
like yeah if you eat a very diet but you
don't you eat like one food a day like
that one food just chicken it's frozen
chicken frozen chicken and monster
that's all he eats that's all like I eat
yeah so like if you eat food right it's
supposed to be like more readily
bioavailable yes so if you are having a
varied diet yeah you can do that yeah
rainbow and all that stuff maybe you
should take some multible some
supplements and I just suggested maybe
he should take some supplements and he's
like I took a blood test seven years ago
and I'm fine a lot can change and said
I wish you were there on my side when
I'm arguing this man it's like are we
but the wall you gotta have more science
at and then he goes you don't believe
give vitamins from the Sun and from
water I'm like did you should go outside
and drink water I saw how much she
drinks this is how much she drank and he
goes I drink so much water and he drank
this much water in four days
that's how much he thinks there's a lot
of water though - oh no I understand
what he's saying cuz he's not wrong
he's not wrong about doing the stuff
that he said yeah that's so [ __ ]
funny because you could get it all from
all the very diet's he goes but you ate
a hot pocket it has protein as batter
and a monster energy drink that he's
gonna show you all the vinyls or do you
see this I love that guy I'm like I have
to pay your hospital bill please just
take a vitamin supplement [ __ ] you
should sneak it in yeah like put a
powder in his monster yeah beads well I
just don't like the way it makes my pee
look like neon green you know what I
found out if you get a high quality one
it doesn't come out neon that's good
that means nothing absorb yeah it's not
being absorbed what do you pay for the
expensive ones they don't that doesn't
happen how do you get the expensive ones
you just buy it got a hookup no I've
been paid so I used to buy like this
cheap-ass like bodybuilding.com one it's
all so I'll just get all everything I
need it's a multivitamin one yeah it's
like $7 for like a three month supply
and then my pee is just highlighter all
the time and then now I have this more
expensive one and well where'd you get
that on accom I tried it too
I don't know if those placebo but I did
feel better on it gonna get a sponsored
post in this recruitment firm they were
they faced a lot a backlash because on
the job description of what they were
looking old as preferably Caucasian oh
Lord
yeah what is it for the branding of the
place cuz if it's like a Renaissance
you can't be having like the Indian guy
and like a Chinese guys do though the
rest of it says who has a good technical
background what if they were casting I
mean what if they were casting for like
actors for Nazis no they're not okay
then we're like hey we're looking for
roles of German descent why would they
say that
what was their defense they said that
they immediately fired whoever was
responsible for that that person does
not make their own decision I have was a
higher-up that was like make sure
they're white okay I want to know the
reason I go the people responsible I
just want to know why because there's
got to be a reasoning behind it right
well I'm pretty sure what happened was
like they had a conversation they're
like hey let's try to get some more
white people on yeah the person was
supposed to internalize that but instead
they were oh well let's put this right
in the job description did say that both
of the owners are Indian Americans and
their workforce is over 60% minorities
that's what I was thinking like a
minority in though it hey we need some
more white people in here man yeah and
so they're saying that they are
certified as a diversity supplier by the
National minority suits so the Indian
guy that was like we have too many too
many minorities yeah we need some white
people here to make it fair and you
trying to be fair maybe people were like
that's racist that's funny we should do
that too much to shoot skits since all
of most of our friends were asians
really yeah we're like we need me
diversity yeah that diverse is placed up
a little bit yeah but we never wrote
like white people only no but when we
cast we did it in the casting process we
didn't like put that up aloo see it all
depends on intent because they're trying
to be diverse by hiring white people
yeah yeah yeah cuz to me that's diaper
night that's diversity for JK because
because there are there aren't that many
like my white people are the minority as
our caste yeah so then that's night of
diversity for us right but that's not
the first thing people think when they
see that diverse yeah yeah they think
they think they're trying white company
that yeah that's what I'm like they
should have just kept it in the process
where you have all these people applying
and then if you want the white person or
whatever then you just
do it I think that's what was supposed
to happen I think it was a conversation
that they had just too lazy it was I'm
done make sure their vibe like foreign
yeah no history everybody's brown brown
maybe white it was like okay why not I
don't know what to see another Indian
face again yeah
if they are brown let it go down flush
it down I don't want it oh yeah so
obviously that sparked a lot of backlash
they do that [ __ ] in China they hire
they specifically look for white people
to hire and it's like they don't even
have to have that the the skills or
anything they just want a white guy in a
suit so then when they looks legit so
they yeah so then when they do like
tours of like their corporate Center or
whatever with other businesses they
could be like and here are the white
people that work for our company yeah
and they're just pretending that they're
working what sucks is now for Indian
guys got fired they pose do you want a
white you would think of white guys are
fired but not for a green guys we were
just trying to be inclusive this is what
you get for diversity okay moving on to
our last story in Washington they have
passed a bill to become the first state
to compost human bodies what are these
are [ __ ] the state legislature passed
the bill and it'll it will only go into
effect of it's signed by the governor
but yeah so they're pretty much allowing
human bodies to be comfortable like
cadavers or like Dookie no like your
batteries yes instead of cremation or
instead of being buried and like
embalmed and being like this very
expensive casket that's not great for
the environment you in soil what does it
do that's revolutionary
can you imagine you're you have some
potting soil and it says made from real
human that's [ __ ] so it won't last
about 5500 which is more than cremation
but less than a burial in a casket I
would they put microbes into this large
vessel that's about eight feet tall and
four feet wide and it will fit a single
body with alfalfa straw and wood chips
and over the course of 30 days
temperatures in the vessel will rise to
150 degrees which then the decomposition
destroys the body and says along with
most pathogens and pharmaceuticals and
it will be safe for you to use that soil
that makes it so sterile I was thinking
like a real compost pile with trash and
worms and dirt and you just get a
[ __ ] dead body and you throw it in
there too I would love that I would love
to die that way and then have my [ __ ]
and then have my kids use it in there
they they yeah they make flowers and
you're like dad's under there I wanted
to be I wanted to be connected to the
bottom of a fruit tree and I wanted to
be grown and then all my graduaiiy
there's a there was a JK article we did
were like they thought that body came
the fig tree looks like fig tree body I
would [ __ ] love that dude and it's
like forever your Grandpa's with you cuz
you this gets popular then you can do
that I would love that
or I want to be compressed into a
diamond oh that's what I wanted to do
with my I don't want to talk about my
cat's but yeah yeah so you could
compress them into a little diamond and
then I want my children to have it in
their front tooth where they're for the
rest of you make your kids do that I
want to be donated to the bodies exhibit
so that millions of people can point out
my dick yeah I still think about it from
time to time while I'm eating you know
that after and I've ordered a hot dog
and I had to slice on dog to eat yeah it
was hard it's because we went through
the exhibit so [ __ ] hungry I'm
I know it was dope but then now I
associate hunger with human bodies very
fickle yeah I didn't like the parts
where they would slice them like this
like I didn't like that I didn't like
any of it
that was dope I thought it was all good
like all the ways they sliced the human
body so you can see how the brain looks
like an infant whales so cool you know
usually I even attend a good picture the
body getting sliced yeah I don't know I
usually tap into that like when I worked
in the hospital and I would see like
actual organs and [ __ ] I could tap into
the oh this is cool as a science medical
stuff whatever but in that exhibit it
just I felt so weird I'm like whoa these
are real people at one point there were
alive like I wanted to see that hole
exist was it because of the Kenny G in
the background what no that that didn't
affect me but it was the fact that I
knew that these were actual real human
beings that had they're all Asian though
you know what help everyone at [ __ ]
eyes it helped me think about every part
of my body you know it's from the
Chinese dissidents right with dead
Chinese dissident it's like well I don't
know Steve always talks about it but
it's like basically prisoners of war
like you know the wrong hold yeah you
mentioned that the Falun Gong yeah Casey
mentioned that as we agree I think
that's what stuck with me the entire
time I walked through it yeah so what
that was some there was too many people
talking so the Falun Gong cult is try is
what is what they're mentioning if
someone's shut up right now the
following Gong result is a political
group that is kind of persecuted or
their their brand in China and then so
the conspiracy behind it is they take
these political prisoners they kill them
and then they donate these bodies to the
exhibit I know that's why I felt like
[ __ ] walking through the whole thing I'm
like oh my god and there was that Haiti
yeah and then there's a pregnant lady oh
my god do you think they were all
Chinese they look all Asian I mean okay
I got [ __ ] eyes it didn't hit me that
they were like like I'm a mind still
separated it until I could see pubic
hairs and then I was like
oh yeah dancehall fat [ __ ] song oh my
dan is a fat ass [ __ ]
damn it was so thick I was like you dead
and small but your [ __ ] so fat and in
the dick
like I was like you guys think Jeff
fake-ass lips I was like damn dude so
nasty she's not thinking about these
dead presence you're like that's a big
[ __ ] you remember what it looks like I
know I basketball actually was like a
basketball looks like that because the
rest of her body got shriveled and so
her [ __ ] looks fatter than it was when
she was alive maybe maybe it wasn't used
to be proportionate could yeah I don't
know I I was just dick I just wish it
was all fake fake things I didn't like
that idea
how would you feel about the fetus one
then had made me even more disturbed oh
my I thought it was cute I really like
to be this one coming oh cool so that's
how big Tycho was at like eight weeks
I'll beg you is that four weeks they
gave me way more appreciation on human
body I can't look at like dead body [ __ ]
dude like even why it's already dead
it's just so nasty and it's too real huh
it's way too real like even when I was
watching the show about obese people and
they will cut them open to see what
their what their livers look like for
people who are moving morbidly obese
I was about to yak as I was watching I
can't watch surgery shows well well how
do you how do you cook and cut fish and
meat you know but that's different
because I don't have an emotional
connection even like a dog is still a
dog you're not I like dogs
yeah I mean if I see a dog cut up and
I'm like no comments but when I see a
person it's it's - its - this this is
too personal
Oh doesn't it make you go wow we're just
like animals that's what it does to me
where I see the light inside the way
from a serial killer I see the inside of
the body and I'm like pig rib human rib
you look at the muscle fibers it looks
very similar you look at just any muscle
fiber and then you go pursue it I was
about to eat a human just to see for a
science experiment or shoot oh he
already said when he thinks of food I
know that's what I'm saying that keeps
getting more and more connected like
it's just like a pig what what's the
difference we could eat it I just think
humans are
big egos where the flesh is just a
vessel but then the way that it's like
we try to separate ourselves so much
from the animal because there's a lot
that separates yes we're like involved
in our communities we have families we
like we got cars that like try it
themselves yeah but that doesn't make
you any higher what what it should do is
you should look at it and go oh we're
actually a lot more closer to animals
you're just saying like flashes a lot of
it is just ideas and being able to speak
and being able to share thoughts and
that is I don't think it makes us gods
it makes us have an emotional connection
that's what that's why it's different
what looking at a human body there but
animals do too they just can't
articulate and vocalize that right but
humans don't always have that emotional
connection to animals as they do to
other humans because they don't have
memories with that animal that's on
their plate they don't have like the
animal didn't invent a Tesla car you
know because that makes me feel closer
to where all I'm eating something that's
like a human - no no no it makes me feel
closer to animals you know I mean you're
an animal lover you should understand
this Joe makes sense to me because okay
this is what I'm saying what I'm saying
is humans are so delusional because they
want to refuse the fact that animals are
very close to us right so you want to
disconnect that it's food because you
feel guilty yeah but I feel like more at
peace with myself
when I come to terms with having the
connection with my food like oh this is
life that's being given to being in the
equation here is that we connect to it
emotionally you can't I do and I know
this is what I'm saying but you're like
you're like me mmm don't you appreciate
the creature more when you understand it
it's closer to you then being a chicken
nugget yeah but for us then we go oh
[ __ ] that's why it's hard for me too
yeah that's what I but so here's my play
about this no no I'm saying yes because
I'm coming to terms with it right you're
in denial we're not we're not
we know that it's closed right yeah no
no but you
trying to refuse the fact so then
because you feel guilty right I know I'm
trying to do is figure what no no we're
not refusing the fact like like for me I
always tell you I struggle with eating
meat and I have to turn that [ __ ] off
because I know how similar we are and
I'm like damn they feel pain they have
emotions they have family they have we
feel guilt because we realize we're so
similar so they don't want to kill that
up right so that's what I'm saying
though is is why is it that if you
understand that why why are you trying
to run away from that I'm saying bring
it closer to you that's the only
difference make it okay morally to eat
something so right and then appreciate
that this is giving you like nourish me
that's not the reason though I think I
think we also because we have you an
emotional attachment we're gonna shut
that they're similar I think the way
that they're dying is unethical and
really [ __ ] up and I don't disagree at
all right so I'm just I'm just letting
you know that that's another angle that
that's like I wouldn't want to die that
way what do you think I'm saying that
we're very similar to animals yeah what
am I saying that's different from what
you're saying we don't help them you
feel guilty new job yeah right and
that's true right motion back to what I
was saying we connected emotionally what
you don't like
since this animals so similar to me I
wouldn't want to die the way that this
animal died I that makes it really no no
but I feel exactly the same way here's
my point I'm saying that I do feel guilt
but I'm coming to terms with it to try
to figure out why because it's a natural
act right but instead of denying that
emotion I'm embracing that emotion and
then not only am i doing that part I'm
appreciating the animal now because I'm
making the connection between human
flesh and animal hmm sounds like you're
more denying the emotion that they are
though because they're accepting the
guilt and they're acting upon the guilt
refusing them night by before you you're
like there is guilt let me reverse the
guilt yeah so you're the one doing the
denial part how is that no no I don't
understand because one is appreciation
and one is denial they're not denying it
they're like okay because this steak is
so close to me like my sister yeah I'd
rather just not what you're still eating
it though right and that's why I'm
saying for me from my specific situation
I have to
turn that part of my brain off cuz so if
you have to turn it off that means
you're in denial instead of appreciating
it for what it is I don't think that
goes hand in hand no so what is what do
you mean by turning that part of your
brain because I feel so connected to it
and because I I I feel like I can feel
what the cow feels or the pig feels and
I know that [ __ ] pigs are are just as
smart as dogs or even smarter right I
had that connection to it and because I
know that they died in an unethical way
I'm like Fogg I wish I didn't enjoy
eating this yeah I mean I totally and
that's why I became a vegetarian because
I'm like damn I can't I can't reverse it
and embrace it and not feel guilty so
yeah I'm not in denial I'm just like oh
I'm very much aware and that's why I
can't get good I don't think the
appreciation deny thing goes hand in
hand yeah I don't think it's one or the
other yeah yeah it doesn't go hand in
hand like that I think that's that's the
only disconnect I think the appreciation
then in your example that I can
understand is if I raised the animal and
then I slaughtered it my yeah yeah yeah
then I feel like I'm appreciating and
respecting you for the life that the
animal gave in order to max when I can
see your point that's why I'm not
against hunters like hunters they eat
what they kill and they like they
respect the animal and they're like I
know they appreciate that you don't
think about food a lot I just eat it I'm
doing this intermittent fasting that's
all I could
[Music]
[Music]